does that seem like an act of domestic
terrorism that you or your justice
department ought to be investigating
absolutely not and i want to be clear
the justice department
supports and defends the first amendment
right of parents to complain as
vociferously as they wish like you i
can't imagine any circumstance in which
the patriot act would be used in the
circumstances
of parents complaining about their
children nor can i imagine a
circumstance where they would be labeled
as domestic terrorism
really welcome back this week
blockbuster evidence allegedly
contradicting that claim by a.g merrick
garland under sworn testimony after
whistleblowers revealed the fbi had in
fact labeled dozens of investigations
into parents with a threat tag created
by the fbi's counterterrorism division
joining me right now the man who led the
questioning for the gop judiciary
committee ranking member ohio
congressman jim jordan uh he's also the
author of the book do what you said you
would do congressman jim jordan thanks
very much for being here this morning
uh your reaction to what we learned from
the whistleblower this week did a.g
garland mislead you there
it sure looks like he did because the
very apparatus they put in motion with
his memo that sets up the line for
reporting then the email that went out
from fbi agents to agents all across the
country that process was used to go
after moms and dads more than two dozen
cases and again he said he wouldn't use
the counter-terrorism measures of the
government to go after parents but that
exactly looks exactly like what they did
and god bless these whistleblowers who
came forward and told us about this
information i mean maria in one case
they went after a mom who was in the
group moms for liberty who actually
owned a firearm which you're allowed to
under our constitution and the person
who purported her on the stitch line
said those were the reasons that she
reported this person and the fbi
investigates so um this is scary stuff
and one other thing think how quick
think of the speed and intensity with
which the fbi did this and the justice
department did this the school board
association sends a letter on september
29th the blast fall five days later the
attorney general does a memorandum to
all u.s attorneys every single one
around the country and the same set up
this snitch line and then 16 days after
that the fbi sends out the email saying
establish this designation this threat
tag label that all happens in 22 days
the intensity they went after parents to
chill speech i have never seen the i
don't know if anyone's ever seen the
federal government move that quickly on
anything but boy when it comes to
chilling speech and going after moms and
dads they were they operated at record
speed
well it seems that they are going after
ordinary americans as we speak not just
parents you've got people locked up
right now if they came anywhere close to
washington for the january sixth uh
situation uh you were subpoenaed i want
to get your answers to this the january
6th committee is subpoenaing you kevin
mccarthy three other republicans about
your conversations with president trump
how will you respond
well i mean again i go back to we got
record crime record inflation moms who
can't get baby for them you know other
moms who are being uh you know the
counter-terrorism measure of the
government doj is coming after them and
this ridiculous partisan committee
is doing the things that they're doing
maria there's a reason 7 out of 10 of
our fellow citizens think the country is
on the wrong track the greatest 70 of
the american people think the greatest
country in history is on the wrong track
because they're what what they're seeing
from the bite administration and what
they're seeing from democrats so this
committee again uh most ridiculous
partisan committee i've ever seen the
first time in american history where the
minority leader first time in the
history of the house represent the
minority leader was not allowed to put
on a select committee the individuals he
or she selected that we have caught them
lying about evidence so uh again what
we'll have to see but
i think the american people understand
just how ridiculous this uh this this
january 6 committee is
well i mean is liz cheney spear heading
this uh was she the one who was who was
leading you know the effort to haul you
in
you know i don't know i i do know i i
actually in some ways feel feel bad for
these people who become so consumed with
their hatred for president trump that
you you can you can almost just sense
the bitterness that they have so much so
that liz cheney was actually recording
her colleagues adam schiff took a text
message that i had forwarded to the
white house chief of staff changed it
altered it presented it in a false way
to the american people so they're
recording colleagues they're lying to
people um all because they're driven by
this this this animosity towards
president trump who i think was the best
president we have had in our certainly
in our lifetimes and doing what he said
he would do so i don't know if she's the
one driving or who's driving it all i
know is frankly we have yet to see the
subpoena they have yet to serve it uh
when we get it we'll take a look at it
but you got to be concerned about a
committee that operates the way this
committee does and has engaged in the in
the in the crazy activities that they've
engaged in um well you just got to be
real concerned let me just say we
haven't heard a word out of liz cheney
on inflation we haven't heard a word out
of liz cheney on the wide open border
and some of these issues around joe
biden's behavior has some of your
colleagues talking about impeachment i
spoke with congressman greg murphy over
on fox business last week uh on mornings
with maria listen to what greg murphy
says as it relates to impeaching joe
biden
president biden has had two
very
clear very very clear impeachable
offenses against the american people
number one the debacle in afghanistan
where he literally said we're never
going to leave americans behind and he
did and number two is the handling of
our southern border you know look this
is the biden's war on america
are you going to move to impeach joe
biden should you get the majority in
november
well well maria first things first we
got to win the majority we got to
continue to take our message to the
american people and talk about all the
crazy things that they're seeing being
done by the buy administration but that
will be a conference decision but look i
do think what's happened on the border
is as wrong as it gets i do think the
way that you know the exit that was from
afghanistan was just just the most
ridiculous thing that we we've we've
seen so um i do think though that'll
have to be a decision made by the entire
conference i think my orcas should be
considered in that category too i mean
look this guy has said the borders
secure umpteen times and we all know
that it's not not the case he's also
said that he is implementing executing
his plan and his plan is intentional uh
being done intentionally to to open our
border wide up and let anyone in by the
policies that they've embraced and the
policies they've gotten they've changed
that were part of the trump
administration so i think maiorkus is
someone we need to consider for
impeachment as well but that'll be a
conference decision that will make if in
fact the american people do what i think
they're going to do which is put us in
the majority in this fall's election
uh kevin mccarthy was on the program a
few weeks ago he says look we're not
going to make this political we're going
to make sure we're doing things that are
right for the american people there's a
lot of debate recently because of liz
cheney recording conversations with
kevin mccarthy do you congressman jim
jordan support kevin mccarthy as speaker
of the house should you gain the
majority
yeah we picked up seats in the last
election uh i think we're going to pick
up seats as i said just just a few
minutes ago and i think we're going to
take the majority my attitude is the
coach that gets you to the super bowl he
gets to coach the game and kevin kevin
has also done a great job leading us
last congress when we had to focus on
the attacks on president trump and the
ridiculous impeachment effort we saw
from from adamship and the democrats so
i think we're going to win and i think
he's going to be the speaker of the
house and i think in two years after
that donald trump's going to run for
president i think he's going to be our
next president
all right we got a lot we got a lot to
watch for uh congressman and thanks very
much for your leadership you got a lot
on your plate and we are certainly going
to cover it thank you sir we will see
you soon congressman jim jordan joining
us this morning in ohio